la barre bonsoir il va bien là moi je
vais très bien la maladie est très
toujours très présente dans le tournoi
parce que je me souviens des loukoums y
avait un dénommé race qui qui qui était
victime de dames syfy comme tu disais à
l'époque
ensuite il ya eu cette histoire du sida
où il ya dans un bouquin on a écrit que
ça fait la route du sida on a dix
navarra le cigare qui m'attendait pas
j'ai pas le sida et tu as obtenu
d'ailleurs complet qu'on coupe les pages
contre non je parle j'ai obtenu
simplement qu'on retient du livre de la
vente
g t [ __ ] j'avais eu une congestion
cérébrale paix des écrans gestion
cérébrale sida oui je le sais puisque
deux premiers à le croire c'était ma
famille ce que je faisais pas au fus oui
j'ai pas vu parce que j'avais le site à
le [ __ ] socialise la famille avait le sida
donc voilà n'est pas le voir et
curieusement comme j'ai comprise ont
quand même venu une fois à chacun mes
deux frères et j'ai compris que j'avais
pas envie que je vis vous avez envie que
je me passe que la cupidité ça existe en
france et sa madeleine et terriblement
envie tu sais comme ça je m'en suis
sorti dès les critères et d'écrire en
général on me dit qu'elle est votre
meilleur roman en question il y aurait
tant on dit pas une mère de famille quel
est le plus beau de vos enfants alors je
réponds je réponds c'est celui que je
vais écrire et bien pour la première
fois jeudi c'est celui je viens d'écrire
c'est l'hôtel stx et chez albin michel
elle raconte nous puisque l'hôtel stick
c'est quand même un hôtel le nom comme
ça se dit que ça fait partie des noms
qui à la fois on peut très bien les
trouver d'ailleurs sur une façade de
cinéma oui tout à fait et puis on peut
c'est aussi la mythologie grecque
raconte nous un peu cet hôtel stx dont
on ne revient pas l'hôtel stx et un
hôtel où on entre et on est su on n'en
sort pas en douceur
on ne sait pas quand mais on ne sait pas
comment ai je n'ai pas pris un
échantillon représentatif de la
population française pour écrire mon
roman comme aurait pu le faire
quelqu'un qui ferait écrire un roman de
marketing
je les écris sans m'en rendre compte
d'abord un roman on ne décide pas de
l'écrit on se retrouve ayant écrit un
roman je me suis retrouvé fin juillet
ayant écrit pendant deux mois j'aurais
nuit hôtel stx il ya une foule de
personnages qui y ce sont les
personnages de la faune ne sais rien je
n'ai pas pris un ambassadeur un an
fernandez j'ai pas pris une vieille [ __ ]
mondaine devenue duchesse j'ai pas non
j'ai pris des gens les gens que j'aime
des gens de partout tout le monde des
hommes des femmes des et puis à la
patronne de l'hôtel stx et puis il ya
son fils
caron caron évidemment puisque c'est
caron qui fait traverser le styx n'est
ce pas oui tu connais le portrait
chinois dont elle portrait chinois c'est
quand le souci je te disais par exemple
mais là bas si tu étais une fleur
d'orchidée on va faire là vers son
affaire nanti portrait chinois
oui
si tu étais un défaut du srec lbp
mangeurs de gâteaux il cite étaient une
injure charognards il était une maladie
isolement c'était un insecte
je serai une mouche pourquoi
parce que des mouches pas empêché de
travailler quand j'écrivais et que le
mouche son opiniâtre reviennent toujours
se mettre à faire de faux pas c'est
infernal
une mouche ne vous empêche de faire la
sieste un mot je peux t'empêcher de
faire un livre
si tu étais un assassin je serai soit
bernard henri lévy soit philippe soler
soit jean edern hallier je tuerai
l'esprit c'était une arme
ce serait une arme blanche très aiguisé
comme les crayons je taime crayon tous
les soirs vous en avez une couche et ça
m'étonne pas si tu étais un poison
je serai critique littéraire est un
collabo
je serai français tu vois qu'il est bien
ce jeu et si tu étais un supplice tu
serais quel supplice libre je serai
directeur de rubrique littéraire dans un
grand magazine
et si j'étais un accident pour finir je
continuerai à écrire et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux